I loved your yard talk about in the
video too I think that about a song if
you can't break it down just like with
just a piano or just a guitar then it's
not a great song yeah that's magic well
that and when we've worked together I
mean it's always like can we make this
work without all the bells and whistles
and if you can then you can put all that
stuff on it yeah we do non kids stuff
too though y'all we've we've lost a lot
of I've lost a lot of money in Vegas but
we've won a lot one time no but that one
time when we won we have been we have
been trying won we won but it was like a
game are you playing well we played on
three-card poker we played slots we
remember at that three-card poker table
where that person came up to you and
said that it was like oh I just love I
love so small so much it's my favorite
song because she's like super hot and so
I'm like maybe I'll just rock it well of
course I'm gonna hind her going I love
you
I loved it no we also karaoke as well we
have karaoke quite a but I have to sell
another a store a karaoke store about
you I don't know if anything we've done
is a time appropriate but um so we would
go karaoke in Nashville which I know you
have an actual connection yes they
should come karaoke okay but um this
woman like she's up there in a wig she
wears this crazy mohawk wig and she's
singing I think you were singing Ice Ice
Baby in my mind but maybe we Donovan
then yeah probably in yeah with a hood
ornament in this woman goes that girl
reminds me so much of Kelly Clarkson I
mean she's no Kelly Clarkson probably D
wrong so I probably wasn't no that's
that was is the most fun place to go
karaoke though I'll eat all the honky
Tonk says well then everybody can really
sing I know but it's good when the bad
ones get up I know right yeah those are
the prime that's like when I get it yeah
it's like Rudy you're like good
so how is your mom I saw her at that
Dallas show I didn't know this but I
read you're pretty I didn't know that
you told your mom whatever you do don't
mention American Idol which I don't know
why you would have done that I don't
care well so have this little show I'm
doing this songwriter show me this is
2006 I mean it's a long time ago and
Kelly was gonna come now this is a small
room of people and my mom is like I just
wanna meet Kelly I just when we Kelly
and I said look I'm gonna introduce you
to Kelly I don't even really know her
that well but I do know that all she
ever hears about his American Idol so
just don't mean which I don't care I
know but I didn't know you and my mom
and my mom said I would never do that
okay so then I say I say mom this is
Kelly and she goes we voted for you
every week I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this